day seven shorts day seven eight twenty
nine a.m. this isn't a real post one
Michelle's not here - I don't know I'm
gonna talk them out I guess I could just
do some highlights not the magazine
that's a good magazine though I liked it
I subscribed highlights we don't have
internet yet don't come home drunk
stairs when you're drunk in the subway
are compatible for each other our
heaters in the morning explode with heat
I woke up yesterday morning and this
morning covered in condensation my
entire room was covered in connotation
because my heater was exploding from the
wall with all this heat they have
attacked it explode them in the morning
when you're home and you're like oh my
god so much heat so nice and then
explode explode explode explode explode
explode when I walk to the subway in the
morning
there are kids just hanging out the top
of the street in my first morning here I
thought that they were getting ready for
to have to fight they were also been
gathered around like anticipating
something and then I found out that that
area is just a bus stop and they were
just
bus other than that things are going
well I think I promise that there will
be more normal vlogs at a later date
thanks bye thanks